alors le premier élément
sur lequel je vous propose de nous
attarder un instant c'est le rapport des
dépenses de retraite à la richesse
nationale une retraite par répartition
ça veut dire qu'on prélève les
cotisations ou des impôts sur les actifs
pour financer les retraites et donc
c'est une manière synthétique de
d'apprécier le
l'effort qu'il faut faire pour les
retraités que de considérer le la part
des dépenses de retraite dans le clip en
gros ça dit c'est qu'il faudrait
prélever sur les actifs je ne vais pas
commenter le passé vous voyez que ça a
fortement augmenté dans les années 2000
le baby-boom la crise économique des
années 2010 vous avez le sou Grosso lié
au covid et puis en 2021 le dernier
chiffre connu c'est les dépenses de
retraite c'est très virgule 8% du PIB
vous voyez ensuite qu'il y a une seule
ligne jusqu'en 2030 parce que là nous
sommes calés sur les prévisions
économiques du gouvernement donc il n'y
a pas de il n'y a pas d'hypothèse à
partir de 2030 vous voyez que il y a
quatre courbes parce que nous sommes
amenés par consensus au sein du corps à
faire des hypothèses sur la croissance
de la productivité horaire du travail
qui détermine le niveau des salaires et
qui détermine aussi le niveau du niveau
du PIB et vous voyez que selon les
hypothèses que l'on prend on a des
résultats différents alors le spectre
d'hypothèse sur lequel nous travaillons
dans leur rapport c'est entre
0,7% de croissance annuelle de la
productivité du travail en gros ce qu'on
a connu entre
2009 et 2019 c'est la plus défavorable
et la plus favorable
1,6%, c'est en gros ce qu'on a connu
entre
1982 et 2022 d'accord sur 40 ans
vous voyez que les résultats sont très
différenciés globalement pour résumer
tout ça même s'il y a quelques vagues
en gros les dépenses de retraite sont
relativement stables vous voyez qu'il y
a quelques vagues et même à long terme
dans trois d'hypothèses sur quatre elle
diminue quelque peu puisque dans
l'hypothèse la plus favorable à mon fini
à 11h 12 % dans l'hypothèse orange j'ai
le précise que l'hypothèse orange 1%
c'est celle qui sert de référence pour
la réforme des retraites c'est c'est le
cas adopter le gouvernement parce que si
nous au corps nous pouvons gérer un
spectre d'hypothèse dans un rapport de
constat pour présenter une réforme il
faut avoir une seule référence et donc
c'est l'hypothèse orange qui a été
retenue par le par le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire pas la plus pas la plus
défavorable mais celle qui suit
immédiatement il n'y a que dans
l'hypothèse grenaste à 0,7% de
croissance de la productivité que les
dépenses de retraite augmentent quelque
peu à l'horizon 2050 puisqu'il passe de
très aiguilles à 14 14